when I first started going to the gym 23
135 lb 6'1 27 in Waist I smoked like mad
and I drank too much like I wasn't in
good shape the first attempts forward I
took in the gym I went to this swim sze
class Jesus it was me in this like
really fat young guy not any worse shape
than me and like seven women over 70 and
they could outswim me it was pretty damn
humiliating and so I did a semester of
that and got myself in somewhat better
shape and then I started to go to the
gym to lift weights that was also rough
because I'd be underneath the bloody
bench press trying to lift 75 lbs and
you know some muscle-headed would come
over and tell me how to do it and it's
like yeah thank you but it's
embarrassing and lots of times people
won't do things like go to the gym
because they're so embarrassed about how
they look or what sort of shape they're
in and it's a pain to start at the
bottom but you start at the bottom where
you're weak and if you want to rectify
what's weak you have to accept the fact
that you're at the bottom and that the
first steps are going to be painful